[Música]
lo anterior fueron 10 segundos de
conversación de un profesor y un alumno
sobre literatura y es que yo les quiero
contar un secreto porque he esperado
estar al frente de todos ustedes por
tanto tiempo no se imaginan la cosa es
que les quiero contar esto hacer que
sean un poquito y pónganme mucha
atención
los jóvenes leemos un icc y si lo
hacemos se los juro cuando yo tenía 12
años derrote a voldemort en la batalla
más épica de roberts
este mismo año gané los juegos del
hambre'
a los 13 me di cuenta que era divergente
y a los 14 tuve aventuras con un amigo
que ustedes conocen como kokoriko
muy buenas tardes mi nombre es léiner
villegas yo tengo 20 años soy estudiante
de publicidad y guía y scouts siempre
listo y les quiero contar que en el 2014
tenía tanta cólera y les comento porque
ese mismo año pues celebramos el día del
cooperativismo en mi colegio cuando ni
siquiera teníamos cooperativa pero no
fui partícipe del día del libro porque
no se celebró ese año
ese mismo año aparte de eso tenía una
frustración enorme no se imaginan las
cosas que recién venía de terminar de
leer
mi libro delirium y no tenía nadie con
quién hablar lo entonces pues hice lo
que cualquier millennial docente ni algo
como ustedes gusta llamarlo pudo haber
hecho en ese momento agarré mi libro mi
cámara me puse al frente de ella y grabé
un vídeo que posteriormente subía a
youtube con el único miedo de que nadie
lo viera sin darme cuenta que en ese
momento me estaba convirtiendo en el
cuarto integrante de lo que hoy se
conoce como el colectivo youtube costa
rica
aquí voy a hacer una acotación ayúdame
necesito saberlo levanten la mano todos
los que habían escuchado la palabra book
tube octubre antes de yo ponerme a que
el frente muy bien ustedes ok
pasa que les va a explicar pues a quien
es un ojo
brooke tube es una plataforma que nace
en youtube donde vemos vídeos y que
desde el 2009 tiene todos estos
creadores de contenido que ustedes
conocen como youtubers pero con el paso
del año desde los años un grupo de
jóvenes llega y dice como mike que
chivas pues yo quiero hacer eso
pero a mí lo que me gusta es leer
entonces agarra el libro se apropia de
él y lo convierte como el objeto
principal para su creación de contenido
esto pues convierte a jóvenes hablando
de libros a otros jóvenes en esta
plataforma
eeuu fue el primero en darse cuenta de
la término octubre pero con el paso de
los años se unieron países
hispanohablantes como méxico colombia
españa luego lo siguió argentina-chile y
no fue hasta el 2014 donde pues una del
canal lectora deliberada sube su primer
vídeo posteriormente lo hace
jean-louis y por cuarta persona pues su
corresponsal yo ok
probablemente pues yo pienso que ustedes
están pensando y que hace un voto ver
cómo son les explico algunos somos bajos
otros somos altos unos son asiáticos
otros somos un poquito más latinos unos
somos jóvenes pero hay hasta profesores
sabemos de todo y qué hacemos cuando
agarramos un libro y una cámara que no
hacemos hemos hecho trailers miniseries
hemos hecho reseñas críticas reacciones
lecturas conjuntas de todo cada uno usa
doctor como le venga a mí me encanta
agarrar el libro y crear contenido que
entretenga y pues le saque una risa a
otras personas
pero carla a carla le encanta hablar de
libros de una manera más fresca y más
juvenil ella ha logrado unir lectores de
méxico españa argentina actualmente
todos leyéndose game friends y no sólo
eso les juro que nadie los va a poder
convencer tanto de leer a stephen king
como ella
louis es alguien que no tiene miedo de
hablar de un libro que es malo cuando un
libro es malo es una es una cara que
está mal les va a enseñar cómo leerse 21
libros en un mes como leerse libros
cuando no quieren leer o como
simplemente leer
y al fin es súper chivas porque él tiene
un calor que se llama el libro college
donde nos enseña a analizar contenido
literario movimientos literarios la
historia la literatura y tiene un
especial todos los miércoles que se
llaman miércoles miércoles donde se lo
dedica únicamente a edgar allan poe
eso somos wood costa rica
probablemente ustedes estén preguntando
ahorita este muchacho vino pararse al
frente a decirme cómo hace vídeos de
libros en youtube no amigos como ya
escucharon yo vengo de limón que es una
zona rural de costa rica y a mi nadie
nunca me dijo que leer como leer ni
mucho menos que leyera uno y les pongo
la metáfora los libros en las zonas
rurales en cualquier parte del mundo son
como el cine o el cine sin películas no
existe un libro si no tiene películas a
esos lugares nunca va a llegar y es que
si tan solo cuando fuéramos jóvenes se
nos acercarán y nos hicieran léete percy
jackson y eventualmente se va a dar
cuenta que se puede terminar la odisea
de homero a los 15 años no crearíamos
que leer es súper aburrido esto me ha
permitido conocer me a mí mismo y saber
cuál es mi tarp eider me interesa quién
es mi villano y es la frase los jóvenes
de esta generación no leen probablemente
algunos los han gustado o la han
escuchado y es una frase muy linda para
reflexionar saben
porque existen o la escuchamos de
personas que la escucharon cuando eran
jóvenes
completamente los jóvenes leemos y
créanme nadie lo hace como nosotros
cuando leemos ponemos cuerpo y alma en
cada palabra cuando yo tenía 17 años mi
mamá se tuvo que sentar conmigo mi cama
y decirme cómo léiner necesitamos hablar
o sea no es normal que usted esté triste
tanto tiempo dígame que tiene le están
haciendo bullying en el colegio mi
chiquito se robar es una mala
calificación ver a alguien le rompió el
corazón
cómo le explico a mi mamá que con 17
años estoy deprimido porque matar a un
personaje de mi libro favorito ridículo
traumático me dijo que yo era pero es
que ya no entiende si si ustedes
utilizan cómo vamos a utilizar la frase
los jóvenes de esta generación no leen
cuando no saben lo que es salir
corriendo a twitter y poner por fin
después de tres libros se besaron o en
el peor de los casos no puedo creer que
acaban de matar a ned stark es súper
difícil para mi amigos leemos si pone en
duda mi palabra los invito a que vayamos
a la feria del libro en el año que viene
y se van a dar cuenta que es imposible
caminar por ahí sin tocarnos al menos 15
jóvenes al frente porque seguimos
utilizando o escuchando la frase los
jóvenes de esta generación los lee les
voy a decir algo sobre los jóvenes de
esta generación somos super sociales
valga la redundancia por las redes
sociales necesitamos entrar en este
sentido de pertenencia sentirnos parte
de un grupo pero pasa que pues
eventualmente todo el mundo sabe qué
a quienes leen los llaman niños niños de
biblioteca ratas de biblioteca net
porque forma directivos con los que se
me describió cuando yo estaba en el
colegio pero yo nunca para leer lo hacía
pero en secreto pero es súper chistoso
ver cómo el incremento de futuver se ha
logrado crear un empoderamiento
literario juvenil donde el joven no se
avergüenza después de lo que está
leyendo y es que hay lectores jóvenes en
costa rica les quiero enseñar este
gráfico que pues donde podemos ver nos
dice que más del 70% de electores de la
comunidad de lectores de costa rica lo
componen los jóvenes en edades dentro de
5 a 35 años la juventud según la ley de
costa rica y no sólo esto este grupo
pues de lectores dentro de 5 a 35 años
su principal motivo de lectura es por
entretenimiento ni siquiera es porque
tienen que leer por el colegio y son
datos que lo respalda el ine que en la
encuesta nacional de cultura
pero entonces qué está pasando ahí
afuera
ok nuestros personajes de autoridad nos
están diciendo que si no leemos a cortar
que si no saben leemos a isabel allende
no estamos leyendo literaturas de verdad
que estamos perdiendo el tiempo en
literatura basura
llega y dice abrimos de esa literatura
de la que dicen que es basura pero
hablemos de libros ok sí porque en el
colegio nos dicen ok es importante ver
como miguel de cervantes hace una clara
metáfora donde dulcinea representa los
deseos inalcanzables de los 15 años yo
quiero saber cómo carnes ganó los juegos
del hambre no quiero generalizar estoy
casi seguro que hay muchos jóvenes de 15
pues que aprecia a miguel ser cervantes
pero no la mayoría y es demasiado chiva
pues estar en este constante creación de
contenido para que el joven pues interés
en la lectura ok
les quiero enseñar por qué es que el
joven se interesa en nosotros lo primero
que hacemos es buscar la manera de darle
al joven el libro que es el indicado
para ellos estamos en una constante
búsqueda que ok si no te gusta este le
voy a dar este otro y si no le gusta
este otro pues tengo este otro para
usted y si no tiene este otro destacó
este otro y aquí hay uno y si no le
gustó pues lo mandó al canal de mi otro
amigo que él probablemente elevar un
libro que le encante hasta que encuentre
ese libro que lo va a entrar a este
mundo
pero no lo hacemos de una manera donde
nos sentamos y hoy vamos a hablar de
cómo este autor viajo bastando hay que
hacerlo de una manera atractiva y
creativa buscando la manera de poder
sentirlos y emocionarnos para que de
esta manera ellos puedan sentir un
sentido de pertenencia en ellos mismos y
pues se puedan sentir en un grupo y es
súper chistoso porque la literatura y la
lectura por muchos años han sido un tema
o una actividad que se hace solo una
actividad individual pero tu club ha
logrado unir a estas personas en tierra
o de manera virtual para que se
convierta en una actividad en conjunto
mi experiencia como
futuver me ha enseñado que los jóvenes
eso es lo que están buscando y yo lo que
quiero es que con cada vídeo ellos
puedan tener la suficiente fuerza para
poder ir donde ustedes profesores y
decirles hoy no quiero leer el diario de
anna frank quiero leer 'crepúsculo' y
está completamente bien porque leer es
lo que importa es el libro probablemente
sea la plataforma para que él llegue al
drácula o al vampiro ok y entonces el
book tube y el boot huber llega y le
abre pues estas puertas le roba tres
minutos de su vida y les dice tengan la
fuerza para decir tengo 13 15 14 17 leo
existo y estoy aquí ustedes profesores
estoy casi seguro que van a poder tener
la oportunidad de algún momento hablar
de ese libro que los va a llevar a una
costa rica de 1920 a vivir aventuras
contigo conejo
es el libro que los va a poder aventurar
en la celda con coco orina o en el mejor
de los casos poder hablarles de ese
libro que les va a contar el relato de
un joven muy apuesto que tiene un que
tiene un
retrato embrujado entonces el libro como
objeto sirve para crear un espacio
intergeneracional cada vez que ustedes
tengan la oportunidad de hablar de él
háganlo porque el libro y los jóvenes
tienen mucho en común aunque ustedes no
lo crean
tenemos tanto que decir pero somos tan
ignorados entonces les pido que cuando
un joven se acerca y quiere hablar sobre
literatura o de cualquier forma
cualquier tema abran los ojos miren que
está sucediendo a su alrededor
escúchenlo cada palabra que está
diciendo y dialogue hablen de lo que él
está diciendo lo que está convenciendo o
lo que está diciendo que lo que él
siente
youtube es una comunidad que está
creciendo cada día por eso los invito a
que si ustedes se quieren convertir en
youtube es bueno para esta manera sanz
nunca es suficientemente adulto entonces
parece al frente de su cámara y hablen
de libros o en el mejor de los casos
inviten a sus alumnos a adentrarse en
este mundo a hablar de literatura les
comento un poco y es que por muchos años
la literatura ha unido generaciones
tanto a profesores como alumnos y es que
estoy casi seguro que ustedes han
escuchado la frase o la frase que dice
como los profesores son los encargados
del futuro de costa rica yo tengo una
visión opinión contraria a esta frase
porque yo estoy seguro que los
profesores son los encargados del
presente de costa rica y el presente de
costa rica están en sus tablas y
escuchando los imágenes en el poder que
ustedes tienen
yo me quiero despedir dándole pues está
este último recordatorio la escritura
empezó cuando descubren los búfalos en
las cuevas de altamira en españa con el
paso del tiempo la escritura y la
lectura llega y descifra estos dibujos y
a partir de ahí en ese momento empieza
nuestra historia la historia del planeta
tierra
con el pasar de los años la lectura ha
estado en piedra en papel en madera en
metal en papiro en todo es momento de
que ahora sepamos que la lectura también
está en internet
en el colegio nos enseñan a leer por una
calificación los invito a que leamos por
pasión y enseñemos eso los invito a que
se agarren de estas plataformas como
youtube para recordar que ahí afuera hay
jóvenes empoderados que están intentando
hablar y alzar sus voces de qué es lo
que realmente les gusta y pues escuchen
los porque al final del día sobre
cualquier tema y en cuanto a literatura
se trata existen estas plataformas para
recordarnos que leer es lo que importa
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]